- [Narrator] Built in
the short economic boom
between two world wars,
the Zollverein Coal Mine
in Germany stands as a
reminder of an industry's past
and an architectural future.
(bright music)
The Zollverein Mine
was decommissioned in 1986,
after being an active
mine for over 100 years.
It was built with conscious thought
for the external appearance,
and during redevelopments
and expansions in the 1920s,
adopted a Bauhaus style of architecture,
which features a modern
symmetrical and industrial feel
and combines form with function.
Today it remains open to the
public as an industrial museum
and is protected as a
UNESCO World Heritage site.
At Zollverein, much of
the former coal factory
has been left in tact,
allowing visitors to view
the pits, railway lines and
even the miners housing.
It is truly a monument of industry
caught in a moment of history.
(bright music)